EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
ADHERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE. NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
AND TO. THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING A
COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE
CAPITAL ALLOW THE ACTS WE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WITH WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. AND
WE'LL ANNOUNCE IT RIGHT NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPATING NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN THREE SEVEN ONE
ONE. FOUR ONCE AGAIN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SEVEN ONE
ONE FOUR FOR DETAILS AND
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO. ARE YOU
THE TELECONFERENCE THIS TOM
PLEASE SEE THE US SENATE OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENTS YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. THIS IS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE SHORT A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER HE
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE. ON MUTE IT AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THIS
CARRYING US IT'S CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO. IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM.
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HALF THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AND
THAT'S CLOSE. TO THE SAME
MANNER AT HIS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY. BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS. WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW ONLINE TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
THREE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAKES. AP ONE
FIVE ONE ONE BY ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE. THAT BILL WOULD BE
PRESENTED ALSO. BY A FAMILY
MEMBER MAZE. AND THEN WHAT TO
ASK VICE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
OMNIBUS BILL AS WELL. FIRST
LESS ESTABLISH A QUORUM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AT JEREMY ON THIS BILL. RUBIO.
RUBIO PRESENT JONES JONES HERE
ARCHULETA HERE ARE TWO LEADING
HERE FACE HERE BATES HERE
PORCHES FURTHER ORDERS HERE DOT.
START HERE BLAZER. WAY SO. HER
DAUGHTER HERE REPORTER HERE
MELINDA'S LENDERS HERE CORTINA.
RIGHT. HERE WE HAVE A CORE. A
CONSULTANT HAS ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY FOUR A SEMI
MAZE WELCOME AND YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH MAN
IN CHAIR AND- SENATORS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT- EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
FOUR THIS LEGISLATION BRINGS
CALIFORNIA LAW INTO COMPLIANCE
WITH REVISIONS TO THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS INSURANCE HOLDING
COMPANY SYSTEM MODEL ACT.
ADOPTED LAST DECEMBER THE N. A.
I SEE IS THE U. S. STANDARD
SETTING AND REGULATORY SUPPORT
ORGANIZATION CREATED AND
GOVERNED BY THE CHIEF INSURANCE
REGULATORS FROM ALL FIFTY
STATES THIS PROPOSAL AMENDS
CALIFORNIA LAW TO ASSIST IN THE
EVALUATION OF INSURANCE GROUP
RISK AND LIQUIDITY STRESS TESTS
AND HELPS CALIFORNIA RETAIN
ACCREDITATION FROM AN A. I. C.
ACCREDITATION HELPS MAINTAIN
STANDARDS PROMOTE SOUND
INSURANCE COMPANY FINANCIAL
SOLVENCY NATIONWIDE. WITH THAT
I HAVE MELISSA GEAR FROM THE
COMFORT OF HOME INSURANCE
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY AS STATED WE
HAVE MELISSA GEAR A CHIEF
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING HAIR
AND MEMBER MELISSA GEAR. KEEP
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
HERE ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA.
APARTMENT INSURANCE. ONE THIRD
OF EIGHTY FOUR POINT NINE FOUR
COMMISSIONER LAR WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SOMEONE NUMBER MADE FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP AND ALSO IMPORT
MEASURE THAT WILL ALLOW
DEPARTMENT OF YOUR STANDARD
INSURANCE COMPANIES FINANCIAL
RISK INVOLVED B. AND RETAIN
CALIFORNIA'S ACCREDITATION FROM
THE NATIONAL OFFICE-
INFORMATION- ANY I THINK.
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY I MEAN
I'D BE UNANIMOUSLY ADOPTED
PROVISION OF REINSURANCE
HOLDING COMPANIES THAT THE
MODEL ACT. AND MODEL REGULATION
IN ORDER TO ENABLE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE CAPITAL
GROUP POPULAR ARTICULATION FOR
INSURANCE GROUP AND THE
LIQUIDITY STRESS HAD FRAMEWORK
FOR LARGE. LIFE INSURANCE
COMPANY. THIS BILL AMENDS
PROVISIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
INSURANCE CODE TO ADOPT. THE
REVISIONS THAT WILL ASSIST IN
THE EVALUATION AFTER SHARON'S
GROUP RATES AND LIQUIDITY TRAP
FOR. CURRENTLY REGULATORS HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO OBTAIN
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
CAPITAL OF NON CURRENT. BUT
THEY DO NOT HAVE A CONSISTENT
ANALYTICAL FRAMEWORK FOR
EVALUATING THAT INFORMATION.
IFILL ADDRESSES THE
SHORTCOMINGS THERE HAVE BEEN
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL METRICS
AND TOOLS THAT WILL BE A BIT OF
AN IDENTIFYING WITH FAMILIAR
WITH FROM A HOLDING COMPANY THE-
IT CREATING. TRANSPARENCY
BECAUSE READ MORE IDENTIFIABLE
AND MORE EASILY QANTIFIED AND
PROVIDES THE DEPARTMENT. LET ME
FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THE BROADER
FINANCIAL MARKETS AND THE
RELATED WITH. A FAILURE A
FAILURE TO ADOPT THIS
REGULATORY APPLE GOOGLE. ON THE
BOOK HAVING A DIRECT EFFECT ON
IMPAIRED BECOME ACTIVE AND HAVE
THEM WORK FOR ME OKAY YOU KNOW.
THANK ON JAN HOOPER TWENTY
THREE. MOST IMPORT THE FOOTBALL
PERFECT THANK YOU VERY
DEPARTMENT THE INFERENCE WITH
AND LOOK FOR THE THREAT OF
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN ORDER TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE FINANCIAL
RISK INVOLVED THE- THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THE FILM. I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
COLLABORATION AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD IN THE PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST I VOTE ON
THE FED'S- AND I ALSO HAVE MY
PHONE ON. THE NET EARNINGS. ALL
PART OF. ON THE LINE IN ANY.
TECHNICAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MELISSA NOW WE WILL
MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY. THE
NON FINALLY WE WILL MOVE ON TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WE NEED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY FOUR AND OPEN THE LINES.
I'D BE GLAD TO LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
ANOTHER TIME I SHALL NO ONE
SHOWING SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
I WILL FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCEDURE WITH ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION- I
DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IDENTIFIED- IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY. IN
THE LINE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN I HAVE NO ONE
SHOWING OPPOSITION THANK YOU
WILL NOW GO TO THE GALLERY TO
SEE THIS ANYONE WISHING. TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION C. NINE
WE WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
C. NINE WILL NOW BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS ANY MEMBERS
WISHING. TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS.
NO QUESTION BUT WHAT I SEE-
SENATOR GORGEOUS. WHEN
APPROPRIATE MOVE THE BILL THANK
YOU ANYBODY ELSE. OKAY MISTER-
A FAMILY MEMBER MAZE YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU- THIS MIGHT BE
THE MOST BORING- BUT NECESSARY
BILL THAT THIS- COMMITTEE WILL
SEE ON HERE WITH THAT I RESPECT
THE REQUEST AND I WILL. THANK
YOU- LET'S CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY RUBIO HI THE BILL HI
DON'T I DON'T I ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA HI. EIGHT FIVE EIGHT
HI FORTIS. BORDERS I THOUGHT I
DOT BY LASER WHY SO HI WAY SO I
RETIRED. THE TIELINE MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S I PORTANT TINA. ROUGH
HI. ROTH HI. BILL HAS TEN VOTES.
IF WE HAVE TEN I WILL PUT THE
BILL ON ON CALL. THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO A B. ONE
FIVE ONE ONE- I UNDERSTAND THAT
SOME INMATES WILL ALSO PRESENT
THIS BILL YOU MAY BEGIN THANK
YOU THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME PRESENT AB FIFTEEN
ELEVEN. THIS IS THE ANNUAL
OMNIBUS BILL THAT CONTAINS NON
CONTROVERSIAL PROPOSALS BUT THE
AUTHOR OF ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
REMOVE SECTIONS THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN FROM THE LEGISLATION
WITHOUT AGAIN I HAVE MELISSA
GEAR FROM THE CALIPHATE
APARTMENT INSURANCE ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. YOU MAY
HAVE. IN THE EARLY MORNING AND
HANG AND REMEMBER THE FLOW OF
THE GEAR THE DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. ABC FIFTEEN ELEVEN
COMMISSIONER MARK WOULD LIKE
THANKS THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON INSURANCE FOR LEADERSHIP AND
OFFERING THEIR NEW OMNIBUS BILL
WHICH FOR MANY OF THE ISSUES
IDENTIFIED BY CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT INSURANCE STAFF
CLARIFY ANYTHING UP OBSOLETE
AND SUPERSEDED ACTION. EIGHTY
FIFTEEN ELEVEN MAKE NUMEROUS
TECHNICAL AND GENERALLY NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES TO
SECTION LEADING TO THE
BUSINESS- INSURANCE. IN KEEPING
WITH THE SPIRIT OF THE PROCESS
I WOULD LIKE TO SET THE
SEVERITY OF THE JOHNSON
AMENDMENT. SECTION THIRTEEN AND
FOURTEEN FROM THE BILL FOR THE
DRUG THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND THE LETTER WHICH.
WE RECEIVED IT LATE TUESDAY
AFTERNOON. BUT THE REMOVAL OF
THE PREVIOUS REFERENCED
SECTIONS WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
IS TRULY TECHNICAL IN NATURE
AND NOT COME TO WORK YEAH.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE AND
THE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
BILL AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED COLLABORATION. THE
MOVE FORWARD IN THE PROCESS.
THANK BYE YOUR EYES ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR CHRIS MCKINLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CLAIMS
PROFESSIONALS AND WE WORKED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AND- BOTH COMMITTEE
STAFFS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE- RELATED TO THE ADJUSTER
BOND REQUIREMENT PROVISIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY ROOM
ONE TWELVE. SEEING NONE FINALLY
WE WILL GO ON TO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPTLY INDIVIDUALS WE NEED TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE IN SUPPORT OF A B. ONE
FIVE ONE ONE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE FIVE
ONE ONE ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO
HAVE ONE Q. CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THANK HIM.AND WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR THAT LINE AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
AT THE PORT OF EIGHTY ONE FIVE
ONE ONE PLEASE PRESS. ONE TO
ZERO AT THE TIME. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE LINE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL WHO
CARES ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
WOULD JUST REALLY LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND THE CONSOLE
THE WORKING WITH THE PROGRESS
OF THE COMPONENTS OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION IDENTIFYING
OUR LETTER- YOU KNOW THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR WORKING WITH US
AND- LOOK ACCORDING TO
BILLBOARD. THANK YOU ANYBODY
ELSE AND I'M VERY NOMINAL. NO
MA'AM NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVING
HEARD FROM THE SUPPORTERS NOW
WILL REPEAT THE PROCESS ANYBODY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION I DON'T HAVE ANY.
REGISTERED EAT OPPOSITION WE
WILL NOW GO TO. THE GALLERY.
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. NOW WE WILL GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. C. NINE. WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCES OR ANYBODY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION UP EIGHTEEN
POINT FIVE ELEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF A B. ONE FIVE ONE
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU TO ALL
OUR WITNESSES- WE WILL NOW.
BRING IT BACK TO MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS. SENATOR RON THE BILL
SENATOR ROB MOVE THE BELL. THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SORRY MR MAYS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THREE BECAUSE I HAVE A
ATM PLEASE CALL THE WRONG.
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY RUBIO HI RUBIO HI JONES.
JONES HI ARCHULETA. SUCH A
LETTER HI BATES. BATES HI
BORDERS ARE BORDERS I DON. DOT
I WAS SO HI. PARMI BLAZER.
PLEASE R. I WASN'T. MYSELF BY
HER TADO. HER DAUGHTER I
MELINDA'S. WINDOWS I PORTANT
TINO. ROUGH ROTH HI. BILL HAS
ELEVEN VOTES. THE BELL HAS
ELEVEN BOTH WE WILL HOLD THAT
PHONE CALL FOR ACTION MEMBERS
THANK YOU MIKE THANKS FAMILY
MEMBER MAZE WE WILL NOW GO TO
CONSENT CALENDAR. THANK YOU
THERE'S ONE BILL ON CONSENT
WOULD FIFTEEN FORTY ONE WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR ROCK.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS THE PASSPORT FIRST
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RUBIO HI RUBIO
HI JONES JONES HI ARCHULETA HI
ARCHULETA I THINK IT'S FIVE
EIGHT FIVE BORDERS THE BORDERS
HI DOT. DOT WHY BLAZER. YEAH IN
ORDER TO- I SENT. HI HI- TADA
TOLD YOU FOR TITLE II MELINDA
FOR EACH. MELINDA'S I FORTINO.
ROTH IRA ROTH HI. BLAZER II.
BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES THIS BILL
HAS ELEVEN VOLTS WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. AND WE WILL TAKE A
SHORT RECESS- TO WAIT FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
FOUR OUT OF TEN MEMBERS.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON EIGHTY FOUR NINETY FOUR FOR
OPEN MEMBERS MEMBERS. GLAZER HI
GLAZER HI FLORENTINO. SEPTEMBER
ELEVEN CALL. OPEN THE ROAD FOR
A. B. ONE FIVE ONE ONE. OKAY I
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR US TO
MEMBERS.
OKAY THAT'S DOING YOUR
YOUR OWN MUSIC GO HAND JUST. TO
SAY HI THIS IS SANDRA. I GRACE
THIS IS SANDRA CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES I CAN HEAR YOU HOW DO I
SOUND. A SHORT RECESS TO WAIT
FOR THE APK MEMBERS THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOW BACK FROM RECESS- WE
WILL CALL. THEM ABSENT MEMBERS
ON EIGHTY FOUR NINETY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MACE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL POURTANT TINA HI
MORTON TINO HI. BILL HAS
TWELVE. THISBILL HAS TWELVE
BOTH THIS BILL IS OUT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON A. B. FIFTEEN
ELEVEN. POURTANT TINA I FOUR
UNTIL I THE BILL HAS TWELVE.
THIS GUY HAS TROUBLE IF THIS
BILL IS OUT WE WILL NOW CALL
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. POURTANT
TINO FOR JULY. BILL HAS TWELVE
VOTES IT HAS TROUBLED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE COMMITTEE ON
INSURANCE IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU.